remarquer c'est plutôt parce que nous
sommes au courant de la façon de se
fabrique quoi
[Applaudissements]
un petit port en Méditerranée tout près
des raffineries c'est au pays de la
bouillabaisse qu'on a inventé le bifteck
de pétrole
monsieur
vous en avez mangé du bifteck de
protéines bon c'est pas lui
c'est plutôt parce que nous sommes au
courant de la façon de se fabrique quoi
comment
va British pétroleum construit en ce
moment à l'aveyra près de Marseille une
usine nouvelle production prévue des
milliers de tonnes par an des milliers
de tonnes qui seront absolument
indispensables à l'humanité de demain
car la production naturelle de protéines
d'origine agricole ne sera pas
suffisante étant donné l'explosion
démographique que connaissent les hommes
[Musique]
c'est le professeur quelle est
l'importance des protéines
dans l'alimentation le régime
d'alimentation humaine et bien les
protéines sont dans l'alimentation
humaine
un besoin constitué pour l'alimentation
humaine un besoin qui n'est pas très
important quantitatif non mais qui
qualitative non et extrêmement exigeant
lorsque
cette ration protéique n'est pas donnée
à l'homme il y a un syndrome très grave
de dénutrition que tout le monde connaît
pour en avoir vu les effets sur les
déportés de la dernière guerre la
production mondiale
en protéines alimentaires
de qualité
convenable
sont
presque exactement suffisantes pour
assurer une ration de 20 g par jour ou 3
milliards 500 millions d'êtres humains
qui vivent actuellement ou plus
exactement qui ont été recensés en 1968
mais il faut considérer que
malheureusement les deux tiers de ces
ressources en protéiques sont consommés
par les nations les plus développées
économiquement de telle sorte que dans
les pays en voie de développement en
particulier le Sud-Est asiatique
l'Amérique latine la ration moyenne en
protéines actuellement n'est que de
10,5 g par jour et par personne et donc
déficitaire déjà de 50%. en 2000 il y
aura 7 milliards je crois 500 millions
d'habitants
je crois que vous avez mis au point un
processus de disons de fabrication de
protéines à partir du pétrole pourquoi
le pétrole
c'est depuis les débuts même de la
microbiologie depuis 1902 qu'on sait
qu'il y a de ces nombreux
micro-organismes qui sont capables
d'utiliser les hydrocarbures du pétrole
comme seule source de carbone et
d'énergie pour opérer leur propre
synthèse et donc pour synthétiser leur
propre protéines c'est une culture qui
se fait très simplement en milieu
liquide dans lesquels on disperse
l'hydrocarbures comme aliment dans ce
milieu là à température
convenable et avec une aération
convenable la levure se développe elle
se développe d'ailleurs remarquablement
vite puisque sur gazole c'est-à-dire sur
mazout comme on dit en France le plus
communément et bien la levure est
capable de doubler de se reproduire avec
un temps de génération de 50 minutes
seulement donc un productivité très
intéressante
c'est une productivité fantastique vous
pouvez nous montrer une de ces levures
oui vous le savez ça n'a rien de bien
spectaculaire vous savez c'est une
petite poudre
voilà donnez votre main
voilà pouvez-vous goûter c'est
absolument inoffensif
goût
du tout peut-être peut-on trouver un
petit goût de champignons de Paris qui
au fond n'est pas tellement désagréable
mais comme vous le constatez on peut
très bien débarrasser la levure de tout
les hydrocarbures résiduels c'est
absolument privé
d'hydrocarbures dans cette poudre
professeur qui est là cette poudre va
nourrir qui
et bien
probablement d'abord les animaux
probablement d'abord les animaux c'est à
dire que
l'usage qui va en étant fait c'est ce
que l'on appelle en anglais
foderiste
levure fourrage
pour l'alimentation essentiellement du
parc et de la volaille
ces protéines de pétrole l'homme pour
aller manger sans danger
certainement c'est tout au moins ma
conviction intime je ne boire aucune
aucun
empêchement majeur à l'utilisation
directe c'est levure pour l'alimentation
directement cependant combien de
souligner comme ça aurait été trop
prudent en cette matière et que il va
falloir
multiplier les tests avant de pouvoir
proposer cette nouvelle source de
protéines comment va-t-on mettre sur le
marché c'est le vu qui va contrôler
justement le
je ne suis pas nutritionniste je ne suis
pas économiste et je ne suis pas
prophète
mais il est évident que il y a de
grandes possibilités
quant à la forme ou les formes sur
lesquelles c'est
peuvent être introduite
l'alimentation humaine on peut d'abord
mélanger cette poudre que vous avez
goûté tout à l'heure la mélanger à la
farine de blé pour donner des galettes
ou des pains de
des pains complets riche en protéines
assimilables et puis il y a beaucoup
d'autres possibilités on va suivre une
par exemple c'est que voyons peut
reconstituer de la viande artificielle
avec ses protéines évidemment c'est la
découverte de nouvelles possibilités
alimentaires dans la mesure où elle
écarte la menace d'une famine
généralisée en l'an 2000 à quelque chose
de rassurant
il ne faudrait pas que l'humanité
s'endorme et se laisse pas trop sécurisé
car ces nouvelles ressources si elles
peuvent un peu reculer les séances
que nous sommes et que je vous soulignez
tout à l'heure ne peuvent que la reculer
mais pas faire disparaître le problème
[Musique]
que c'est une extrapolation à l'absurde
que quelque chose va se passer avant
mais que va-t-il se passer
est-ce que la courbe démographique
sera infléchi
par une catastrophe
c'est bien possible la bombe atomique
ou encore une grande pandémie la peste
un virus
mais alors il faudrait une catastrophe
considérable si l'on considère que les
génocides des deux dernières guerres
mondiales
n'apparaissent pas
sur la courbe démographique
il faudrait donc
s'il s'agissait d'une catastrophe qu'il
s'agisse d'une CATastrophe sans commune
mesure avec tout ce que l'humanité a
déjà subi il y a une alternative
alternative c'est que enfin les hommes
rationalisent
leur rapport et
leur structure
aussi bien sur le plan international à
l'intérieur de chacun des pays
mais je vous avouerai que
dans le climat politique
actuels
à cet égard
[Musique]